cakes cookies and brownies no we're not
going to show you how to make them
because they can be made with ease
thanks to betty crocker who was born in
1921 in minnesota
well kind of
[Music]
in 1921 the washburn crosby company now
known as general mills ran a contest for
people to complete a puzzle for the most
coveted prize a pincushion yes one of
your very own
surprisingly a lot of people wrote in to
claim their prize but with a little ps
how do i make my sponges
they wanted baking advice
so the customer service department began
to reply and to make their tips seem
more genuine they signed their letters
betty crocker
betty because it was a cheery all-around
american-sounding name and cracker after
a board member
not being a real person didn't stop
betty crocker from having a very
successful radio show the betty crocker
cooking school of the air
with a different accent in every state
but the lies don't stop there let's talk
about that added ingredient the egg
you don't need to add a fresh egg to
powdered cake mix but science says it
makes us feel like we aren't cheating
and we're better providers
so thanks betty crocker for making us
all feel like we know how to bake
[Music]
you